so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host carlwood yes that is my real name
and today we're talking about Charles
Pretty Boy Floyd America's Robin Hood
Outlaw and as with all the videos here
at biographics this one is based on
original script submitted To Us by a
member of our writing team that being
Radu Alexander you can follow the social
media links below and while you're down
there why not leave a like a comment
with feedback or suggestions and
subscribe to the channel normally we'd
say that after the video because that's
where it makes the most sense but
analytics show that me saying it before
the video means all three of those
things are more likely to happen because
I I don't know YouTube's weird about
that I
guess if you'll gather around me
children a story I will tell about
Pretty Boy Floyd and Outlaw Oklahoma
knew him well yes he took to trees and
Timber to live a life of Shame every
crime in Oklahoma was added to his name
but many a starving farmer the same old
story told the outlaw paid their
mortgage and saved their little homes
others tell you about a stranger that
came to have a meal underneath his
napkin he left a $1,000 bill those words
come from The Ballad of Pretty Boy Floyd
a song by American folk icon Woody good
3 it perfectly encapsulates the complex
and controversial Legacy left behind by
one of America's most notorious Outlaws
Pretty Boy Floyd was a robber in a
killer there's no doubt about that he
actually became the country's new Public
Enemy Number One after the death of John
Dillinger and yet to many people he's
remembered as the so-called Robin Hood
of cookson hills for his generosity
towards the needy and most famously for
allegedly burning morgage documents
whenever he robbed a bank to get people
out of debt but was this reputation
deserved or did Floyd simply benefit
from some good old fashion postmortem PR
let's find out shall
we Charles Arthur Floyd was born on
February 3rd 1904 that's a day after my
birthday in ad Arville BTO County
Georgia the fourth of eight children of
Walter Lee Floyd and Mommy Helena CO's
his father first worked as a railroad
fireman then as a minor until he found
his calling as a farmer in 1911 the
family packed up their bags and moved to
Hansen Oklahoma where they grew crops
and a little plot of land The Floyds
lived on the southern edge of cooken
Hills a large area covered in thick
underbrush with few poorly maintained
roads to get around it had a reputation
of being a favorite hiding spot for
people in trouble with the law and many
of fed outlaw found refuge in the
cookson Hills Growing Up Young Charles
heard the stories of Infamous nwell such
as Bill Duan Bell star and the Doan gang
who all passed through the cooks and
Hills at one point or another in
particular though young Floyd became
particularly fascinated with the
exploits of a Kansas criminal named
Eddie Adams who wound up in those parts
after executing a daring Escape or being
taken to prison by train after a few
years in Hansen the family moved to a
bigger farm near Akin where the Floyd
grew their own food and their own
livestock they also made their own
cornmeal lad soap and other items using
food byproducts and soon enough Walter
open a general store in Atkins to sell
extra Goods overall Charlie as his
family called him had a pretty happy
childhood he was described as being
friendly outgoing boy who was fun to be
around who loved and respected both his
parents and was protective of his
siblings there were just two issues
within there one he wasn't exactly the
valid Victorian material once he knew
how to read and write and do some basic
arithmetic he was like I'm done that's
enough for me and left school in the
sixth grade and the other issue is that
Floyd really really didn't like hard
work and he he did do hard work because
he was tall but he never really saw it
as his future and Charlie began drifting
down the a darker path as a teenager he
started quite small as most career
criminals do with some fights and some
minor petty theft he even risked a
little jail time in 1923 when the then
18-year-old Floyd was arrested for his
role in a post office burglary but lack
of evidence and testimony from his
respected father kept him out of The
Slammer at least for now when he wasn't
getting into scrapes or trouble with the
law Charlie was only interested in one
thing girls and they were certainly
interested in him he wasn't called
pretty boy sarcastically or anything
Charles Floyd was a strong and handsome
young man who liked to be well-dressed
and well groomed his family did make
soaps that makes sense and some say this
is how he gained his famous nickname but
there are several contradicting Origins
for the Pretty Boy Monica so we're not
exactly sure where it started we know
one thing for sure though Floyd hated it
but it's stuck he was hardly the only
criminal that didn't like his nickname
by the way George Nelson hated being
called Baby face and if you dared called
Ben seagull Bugsy to his face you risk
catching a beating even a bullet those
are all Shameless plugs by the way we've
already covered those gangsters if
you're interested like finish watching
this video first if you saw have a
hankering for some true crime they're
all sitting there in the description uh
just waiting for you to click on and
improve our analytics so back to Floyd
another nickname he'd had since he was a
teenager was chock due to his fondness
for chock tow beer he probably would
have preferred everyone call him chalk
Floyd but it didn't have the same ring
to it anyway in 1924 the 20-year-old
Floyd married a 16-year-old farm girl
named Ruby Hargrave described as having
dark eyes open hair and a pretty face
they had a son named Charles Dempsey
Floyd and the three of them lived in a
log cabin not far from the family home
in Akin and Charlie decided to give the
whole farming thing a go but this was
not up his alley so in 1925 Pretty Boy
Floyd set off to look for shall we say
Alternative forms of
income
during that Year's Harvest Floyd met
Fred hilderbrand a two gun toting ham
who unlike pretty boy got his own
nickname so he went by the Chic because
he looked like Rudolph Valentino or at
least he thought he did and who's going
to argue with a guy with two guns
hilderbran was laying low after robbing
an electrical Manufacturing Company of
over $1,800 and he told Floyd of all the
easy targets the two of them could hit
together and convinced him to tag along
in August 1925 Floyd got himself a
revolver kissed his family goodbye and
traveled with the Chic down to St Louis
that month alone the criminal Duo robbed
multiple grocery stores and gas stations
in September their Ambitions grew and
they robbed the payroll being
distributed to a Kroger food store's
headquarters afterwards while talking to
the press the pay Master described Floyd
as a pretty boy with apple cheeks and
this is another potential origin story
for the Pretty Boy nickname the robbery
might have been a success but Floyd and
hildbrand started spending money like
there was no tomorrow this made the
police suspicious and when the
authorities picked them up for a quick
chat they found thousands of dollars in
cash on them as well as money rappers
from the bank Floyd plad guilty and
eventually was given 5 years at the
Missouri State Penitentiary his wife
actually only found out about his
extracurricular activities as we're
going to call them after he was arrested
when she read about them in the papers
she divorced him while he was serving
out his sentence Floyd was paroled after
3 and a half years but he had no
intention of going straight in fact he
made quite a few criminal connections
inside prison and when he got out he
made a be line for Kansas City Missouri
but before Floyd could do any serious
damage he received some quite
heartbreaking news from back home his
father had been killed by a neighbor
named JY Mills during a fight over some
Lumber Floyd returned to cookson Hills
for the funeral and trial but Mills was
quitted on the grounds of self-defense
Mills mysteriously disappeared after
that and his body has never been found
whether or not we can actually ascribe
this murder to Pretty Boy Floyd we can't
say for sure although he made it quite
abundantly clear in the years that
followed that he had no quarms about
taking a life so Floyd only returned to
Canvas City for a short while but it was
enough to attempt to assassinate a
detective Ive named Bert hok who' been
causing way too many headaches for his
underworld Associates hok survived this
encounter with the outlaw and because
the detective saw his face Floy thought
it best to find greener pastures he
joined with a prison body named James
Bradley and headed to Ohio Bradley's
gang first committed a series of
robberies in and around Toledo then they
moved on to Acron where things went
South quickly while driving Bradley
accidentally crashed his car into an
oncoming vehicle as two policemen rushed
to the scene he panicked an open fire
killing patrolman har and Mains after
that the Aron Police Department
Department was out for blood and scoured
the city until every member of the gang
was captured Bradley was sentenced to
death for the murder while Floyd and the
others were given 12 to 15 years for the
robberies and it looked like this would
have been the end for pretty boy but he
escapes on the way to prison emulating
his childhood hero Eddie Adams during
the train ride he smuggled a handcuff
key under his tongue asked to go to the
bathroom and after uncuffing himself
broke the window and jumped out of the
train Floyd had sworn he would rather
die than go back to prison and spoilers
ultimately he would get his wish
on the run from the law Floyd opted for
familiar surroundings and returned to
Kansas City where reunited with a lover
named Juanita bird he also teamed up
with a ruthless Outlaw named Billy the
Babyface Killer Miller a much more
experienced criminal with an admittedly
less cool name already having 28 arrests
and five murders to his name together
they planned a spree of robberies up and
down the country but before leaving
Kansas City there was one final mat to
take care of Miller had hooked up with
Juani Sister Rose after he left her
husband William Ash who was also a
malevolent malactor of the city's
criminal classes allegedly Williams and
his brother Wallace R out Floyd and
Miller to the police trying to get them
arrested or killed either one would have
worked fine but the Outlaws managed to
escape and they wanted Revenge one night
the ashs were lured to a meeting by a
phone call from a woman their car was
found on fire by the side of the road a
few hours later their bodies in a ditch
next to the road both shot in the head
no prizes for guessing who did them in
afterwards the forsome Floy Miller
Juanita and Rose left town and intended
to go on a rampage through Missouri
Oklahoma Kentucky and Ohio however the
team up was shortlived and ended after
only two bank robberies on April 16th
1931 the gang was in Bowling Green Ohio
the two men were at Barber Shop while
the women were doing some shopping but
someone recognized their faces and
called the police chief of police Galah
here and patrolman Ralph casner
approached the men and a shootout ensued
one shot from G here ripped open
Miller's neck and the Gman was dead
before he hit the ground Juanita also
caught a bullet but she made a complete
recovery Rose was captured and this only
left Floyd confronted by patrolman
kasner pretty boy emptied his gun into
him shooting him seven times before
getting the hell out of Dodge All Alone
cner died a week later following the
murder Floyd was as hot as a supernova
and even before this he gained a certain
level of infamy mainly because the
papers love writing about the exploits
of the Pretty Boy Criminal Who robbed
banks and escaped from custody but now
he truly was one of the most notorious
Outlaws in the entire country Floyd
needed a place where he could lay low
until the heat died down so it was back
to Kansas City for him pretty boy hid in
a flower shot which is the front for a
liquor business alongside another
gangster named John Calo who was also
wanted for murder on July 20th 1931 the
police and prohibition agents raided the
flower shop special agent Curtis Burks
had The Misfortune of running into Floyd
in the back room of the place Floyd
killed Burks without hesitation then
shot another three law enforcement
agents he was making his getaway but
they all survived their injuries an
innocent bystander was hit and killed
during the shootout and lastly when CIO
refused to surrender he went for his gun
a policeman basically disintegrated his
entire head with a point blank shotgun
blast so yeah overall a pretty bloody
Affair which ended with Floyd once again
free and on the run on his own with
Kansas City in his rear view pretty boy
headed home to the cooks and
Hills so Floyd felt pretty safe in The
Familiar environs of cooks and Hills but
he had no intention of stopping his Crim
spring there were people to be robbed if
anything he actually accelerated it he
teamed up with a childhood friend named
George Birdwell later adding a few more
members to his crew becoming an official
gang leader in his own right together
they committed dozens of robberies in
1931 and 1932 although the exact number
of crimes the gang perpetrated is
difficult to pinpoint as noted in the
song at the beginning of this video that
I butchered almost every robbery in and
around Oklahoma at the time started
being attributed to Pretty Boy Floyd
including those he had nothing to do
with and the papers knew that stories
about the pretty boy would sell pretty
well so rarely did a few days go by
without at least one mention of the
local criminal Superstar sometimes Floyd
was accused of robbing two banks at the
same time his City's miles apart from
each other other TI's newspapers report
that Floyd would taunt the police about
Banks he intended to Rob for example one
in anola Oklahom one local newspaper
wrote that Floyd wouldn't dare to rob
that place because during the previous
five attempts all the criminals were
either captured or killed and Floyd
supposedly wrote a letter to the police
saying I'm going to rob that bank though
the reward on Floyd's head due to all of
these crimes total some $66,000 Dead or
Alive there was even talk of the
governor bringing in the National Guard
to hunt him down he was starting to
attain almost mythical proportions in
Oklahoma with some yokal even spreading
rumors that Floyd always escaped the law
because he was and I quote immune to
gunfire he wasn't as you'll soon enough
find out so this was also around the
time that his Robin Hood Persona began
taking shape the Great Depression had
hit Oklahoma and hit it hard many people
struggled to feed their families and
risk foreclosure on their homes but then
Pretty Boy Floyd rode in like a hero to
save them how did he do this you ask
well supposedly whenever he robbed a
bank he would destroy all of the
mortgage documents to protect people
from foreclosure which sounds quite
Noble the question is did he ever
actually do this and the answer is a
rather unsatisfying we we we don't think
so pretty much every Solid Source only
describes this act of benevolence as a
rumor or a legend and even the FBI
reports that Floyd might have done this
once or twice possibly by accident but
it was certainly not a usual part of his
modor operandi it's probable that Floyd
did bring food for starving families
from time to time or gave them money
directly but this was not a completely
selfless act either it was more a
gesture of thanks for not turning him
into the authorities because as
mentioned he had a quite large bounty on
his head at the time and he knew such a
reward would be awfully tempting to
someone in di Straits as most people
back then were overall he made a pretty
poor Robin Hood especially when you
remember the whole killing people thing
that he did a lot his next victim was
special investigator Irvin a Kelly a
former Sheriff of Macintosh County who
had been tasked with the capture of
Oklahoma's most notorious criminal and
it's worth noting that killing Kelly was
no simple task because he had a pretty
stellar reputation having captured 14
bank robbers and six murderers during
Floyd's time back in cookson Hills he
had reunited with his ex-wife Ruby and
his son and Kelly knew that they were
the perfect Bay and that if he stayed on
their tail before long Floyd would show
up and show up he did on April 9th 19 32
Kelly prepared an ambush outside a
farmhouse a few miles west of Bixby he
beli Floyd would meet with Ruby the
Lawman had six veteran agents and two
deputized farmers with him but as the
hours passed and Floyd was a no-show
people were starting to get cold and
hungry and just tired of being outside
holding a gun Kelly allowed his men to
take a break around 3:00 a.m. staying
behind with only the farmers this was
his first and perhaps most fatal mistake
putting his trust in untrained civilians
who hid in the dark when the shooting
started minutes later a car pull pulled
up with Floyd inside submachine gun in
hand Kelly stepped in front of the
vehicle and issued a warning this was
his second mistake allowing Floyd
timeing to surrender instead of
immediately opening fire on the known
Criminal Who Shot everybody who tried to
arrest him of course pretty boy did not
hesitate and immediately fired his gun
hitting Kelly four times the lman
managed to squeeze off some shots but
only hit Floyd in the legs the car sped
off as Kelly collapsed to the ground and
died of blood
loss
the summer of 1932 was a relatively
quiet one for Floyd as he laid low to
let his gunshot injuries heal but by
October he had already recruited a new
gang and was ready to get back to what
he did best Robin Banks the close call
he had with Kelly did not deter him one
bit in fact he was so cocky that he gave
an interview to a reporter from the
Oklahoma news the literary diges
proclaimed him Oklahoma's Bandit King in
his December issue and he even started
having impersonators but which mean
other robbers who claimed to be him
during their heists anyway November of
that year Floyd's partner George
Birdwell was shot and killed during a
robbery in Bley Oklahoma and you'd think
that Charles Pretty Boy Floyd would mour
the loss of his childhood friend but no
not really there were Banks to Rob so he
went right back to robbing more Banks
after finding himself a new partner and
this partner was a short balding Texan
by the name of Adam retti and together
they spent the first half of 1993 up to
their old trinks robbing banks however
things took a drastic and quite violent
turn in June of that year when Floyd was
involved one of the most audacious
shootouts in the country's history
became known as the Kansas City Massacre
and on June 16th 1933 an escape Outlaw
called Frank Nash been apprehended in
Hot Springs Arkansas three agents were
taken in by train to Kansas City
Missouri where a team of Boi agents
that's bureau investigations the
precursor to the FBI the federal bureau
investigations and police officers were
waiting to transport Nash to leworth
Penitentiary some of nasha's criminal
bodies had other ideas however and
planned to bust him loose on the morning
of June 17th the The train pulled into
Union railway station four officers went
to meet up with the three already
guarding Nash they were all armed with
pistols and shotguns together they
escorted The Prisoner to apart Chevrolet
as the agents were getting into the car
they saw movement from a nearby green
Plymouth three men quickly surround the
Chevrolet and one of them shouted let
them have it at that point all three
open fire with machine guns after
emptying their magazines into the car
one of them approached the vehicle and
said they're all dead let's get out of
here in reality only five of the eight
men were dead the three survived the
attack Frank Nash was among the dead um
by the way since he was right in the
middle of the whole ordeal so worst
escape attempt ever I guess in fact the
way it all went down maybe people think
that it was never meant to be a rescue
attempt in the first place but a hit to
silence Nash according to the FBI the
three gunmen were Floyd retti and
another guy named Vernon Miller Miller
was found dead a few months later
executed Gangland style which helped
further the theory that someone was
tying up Loose Ends regarding Nash's
assassination although to be fair Miller
was the kind of guy who had lots of
people want him dead for a variety of
reasons as to Floyd and richetti the FBI
gathered pretty solid evidence that they
were the other two trigger men pretty
boy sent a postcard to the Kansas CPD
denying any part in the massacre even
though he was already wanted for
multiple murders and dozens of robberies
why or how they got involved in this
remains uncertain to this day so we
apologize for not being more clear in
that
regard for the first time in his career
the co
had left pretty by Floyd there was a
nationwide manhunt for him and he felt
the news tying around his neck Floyd and
reeti met up with Wanita and Rose bird
who had been released from prison and
the four of them traveled to Buffalo New
York rented an apartment under an
assumed name and kept a very very low
profile 1934 was a big year for law
enforcement first Bonnie and Clyde were
gone down in May then in July John
Dillinger bit the big one and then in
November Babyface Nelson was killed in a
shootout between Dillinger and Nelson
though it was Floyd's time to go go in
October 1934 the forsome decided to
return to Oklahoma but just a few hours
into their trip they crashed their car
into a telephone pole just outside of
Wellsville Ohio while Rose and Wan went
into town looking for a garage local
police chief Jay folz and a couple of
officers investigate reports of two men
loing around a forest outside of town
they run into Ree and Floyd and a
gunfight ensued there were a few minor
injuries on both sides but no deaths and
the cops managed to capture reeti alive
setting him up for a date with the gas
chamber a few years later Floyd on the
other hand managed to evade authorities
once again but he was on foot and he
knew that a search party would be right
on his tail he made it to East Liverpool
Ohio before the law caught up to him and
Floyd did try to hide in the woods but
the officers opened fire with pretty
much everything they had at their
disposal think that scene in Rambo first
Blood like just without the rocket
launcher and despite potentially
hundreds of bullets being shot in his
Direction only two actually hit Floyd
but they were enough to take him down
after stumbling a few yards Floyd
clutched his wounds and fell to the
ground he exchanged a few words with the
officers mostly
yelling
especially twice again before saying I'm
done you got me his last words were
apparently I'm going and then Pretty Boy
Floyd was dead so I hope you found this
video educational informative and
entertaining I certainly found the
script to be all three of those things
and if you'd like to thank the script
auor you can find them at the social
media links linked below you can also
find my own if you want to follow me you
can also find links to follow our sister
channels Geographics and top 10s where
I'm also serving as the interim host
thank you to everyone for watching at
home like would appreciate if you like
the video left a comment with feedback
suggestions that sort of thing or
subscribed as mentioned but otherwise
hope everyone out there has the day that
they
deserve